die rede ist von zitat signifikanten
mengen an wasser aufgespürt im wall
marin er ist dem grand canyon des mars
das riesige wasserreservoir wurde jetzt
direkt unter der oberfläche des roten
planeten aufgespürt und zusammen mit der
hilfe des exomars trace ob das tgo
selbst die fachleute sind über die große
menge an wasser erstaunt wird die
besiedlung des mars jetzt viel einfacher
klick zum science im future gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos aber in ihren kanal und aktiviert
die glocke so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
herzlich willkommen das neu entdeckte
wasserreservoir sorgt für aufregung in
der fachwelt laut den esa
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern handelt es sich um ein
gebiet das etwa die größe der
niederlande hat es versteckt sich unter
der oberfläche des mars und zwar im wall
marie näheres ein weitläufiges
grabenbruch system auf dem roten
planeten das sich entlang des äquators
im osten der vulkanischen tarsus region
erstreckt dazu sagt einer der
beteiligten forscher metro fahrer vom
weltraumforschungsinstitut der
russischen akademie der wissenschaften
wir haben festgestellt dass ein
zentraler teil von wall marie theres
voller wasser ist viel mehr wasser als
wir erwartet haben wie wurde das riesige
reserven wasser entdeckt um welche form
von wasser handelt es sich kann es
möglicherweise bei zukünftigen mars
missionen genutzt werden die spannenden
antworten auf all diese fragen und alle
weiteren infos zu der spektakulären
entdeckung auf dem roten planeten gibt
es jetzt hier bei pixum science im zu
ziehen fest steht da wo wasser ist ist
leben zumindest gilt flüssiges wasser
bei uns auf der erde als die grundlage
allen lebens forschende suchen deswegen
bereits seit vielen jahren sehr intensiv
nach flüssigem wasser auf dem roten
planeten gar nicht so einfach denn der
mars gilt als kalt und trocken in
gletschern und in den eiskappen der
messianischen pole gibt es wasser doch
fast nur in form von eis oder
wasserdampf flüssiges wasser müsste
wegen der dünnen mars atmosphäre an der
oberfläche eigentlich innerhalb von
sekunden verdunsten doch ohne frage wenn
er irgendwann flüssiges wasser auf dem
roten planeten aufspüren würden wäre
dies eine echte sensation denn solch
eine entdeckung würde nicht nur die
menschliche besiedlung des mars
erheblich vereinfachen solch ein fund
wäre auf die grundlegende basis dafür
dass auf dem mars ehrt ähnliches leben
entstehen könnte oder bereits entstanden
ist bis vor einigen jahren hatte man auf
den mars nur winzige spuren von
flüssigem wasser aufspüren können und
das trotz intensiver suche
beispielsweise hatten sich auf den nasa
lande modul phoenix wassertropfen
niedergeschlagen in der äußerst dünnen
luft des mars befindet sich also ein
geringer anteil an wasserdampf das war
es aber auch schon fast an hinweisen
dennoch hatten einige forschungsteams
schon seit rund 30 jahren spekuliert
dass es unter den polkappen es flüssiges
wasser geben könnte hundertprozentig
sicher sind sich forschungsteams
allerdings bislang nur dass es mal vor
milliarden jahren wasser gegeben haben
muss denn darauf weisen ausgetrocknete
sedimente und flussläufe hin und so
wurde in den letzten jahren eifrig
diskutiert gibt es auf dem mars
flüssiges wasser oder nicht hatte
vielleicht sogar mal ein ganzer ozean
den mars vor langer zeit bedeckt stand
der dinge bis heute wasser wurde bislang
in der form von eis vorrangig an den
polen gefunden an der oberfläche konnten
auf niedrigen breitengraden bislang nur
geringe mengen nachgewiesen werden doch
jetzt die neue wirklich bahnbrechende
entdeckung es handelt sich tatsächlich
um unmengen an wasser in der region
namenswahl marie näheres auch als marina
teller bekannt dieses grabenbruch system
zieht sich über eine länge von 4000
kilometern und bis zu 700 kilometer in
die breite und tiefe täler oft zu recht
wird dieses system deswegen manchmal
auch als grand canyon das maß bezeichnet
die fachwelt ist schon seit langer zeit
ganz besonders an diesem canyon auf dem
mars interessiert weil er an den
berühmten grand canyon in den usa nr
dennoch gibt es einen gewaltigen
unterschied der mars canyon ist ungefähr
zehnmal so groß und fünf mal tiefer und
genau in dieser region konnten die
forschen jetzt ihre neue entdeckung
machen laut der fachleute handelt es
sich um zitat
signifikante mengen an wasser das gebiet
ist laut der aktuellen analyse etwa
42.000 quadratkilometer groß und somit
vergleichbar mit der größe der
niederlande bis zu 40 prozent des
materials direkt unter der oberfläche
könnte wasser sein so schreibt das
forschungsteam das in der aktuellen
studie fest steht wohl dass es sich im
ersten meter des bodens befindet noch
nicht endgültig geklärt dagegen ist der
aggregatzustand des wassers die
messungen geben darauf keine finale
antwort andere daten und analysen aber
legen nahe dass es sich um gefrorenes
wasser handeln könnte dazu schreiben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
wir haben herausgefunden dass ein
zentraler teil der wall marie theres
voll mit wasser ist viel mehr wasser als
wir erwartet haben das ähnelt den
permafrost regionen auf der erde wo
wasser als aufgrund der konstant
niedrigen temperaturen unter dem
trockenen boden dauerhaft bestehen
bleibt insgesamt denken wir dass dieses
wasser hier in form von eis existiert
die entdeckung die sogar die fachleute
selbst überrascht gelangen mit dem
exomars trace gas ob peter kurz tokio
der europäischen weltraumagentur esa er
befindet sich bereits seit fünf jahren
2016 in der umlaufbahn des roten
planeten es handelt sich im wahrsten
sinne des wortes um einen schnüffler tgo
hat das große ziel die atmosphäre des
mars genauer zu untersuchen haben gase
wie methan und andere spurengase die
sich dort befinden biologische oder
geologische ursachen insgesamt ist der
tgo mit vier instrumentengruppen
ausgerüstet diese sind zwar spezifisch
in ihren aufgaben ergänzen sich dabei
aber gut beim aufspüren des aktuellen
fundes dem überraschenden
wasserreservoir hat das instrument fremd
eine entscheidende rolle gespielt die
abkürzung steht für fein resolution app
store manager detektor und seine
hauptaufgabe ist es den von der
marsoberfläche ausgehenden neutronen
fluss zu messen dieser entsteht durch
das stetige bombardement der oberfläche
durch partikel der kosmischen strahlung
diese treten dann in wechselwirkung mit
den atomen in den obersten metern der
gesteine und böten des roten planeten
somit ist dieses instrumentes tokio also
nicht nur in der lage einblicke in den
gas verlust der mars atmosphäre in den
umgebenden weltraum zu bekommen die esa
forschenden können mit seiner hilfe auch
gebiete erkennen die höhere gehalte an
wasserstoff aufweisen denn das
instrument fahndet nach neutronen die
von der oberfläche stammen und auf
wasserstoff hinweisen und je nach
feuchtigkeit unterscheidet sich dann
wehren menge je mehr wasserstoff desto
weniger neutronen dazu erklärt der
wissenschaftler alexej malakhov
neutronen entstehen wenn buch
energetische partikel die man als
galaktische kosmische strahlen kennt den
mars treffen trockener boden strahlt
also mehr neutronen ab als feuchter
boden und so können die fachleute
ableiten wie viel wasser sich im boden
befindet zugute kam ihnen dabei das feld
eine bessere räumliche auflösung
ermöglicht als andere instrumente dazu
sagt igor mitrofanow auf der an der
aktuellen studie beteiligt ist mit tgo
können wir sehen was wirklich unter der
oberfläche des mars los und können
wasserreiche oasen lokalisieren die mit
vorherigen instrumenten nicht entdeckt
werden können dass das instrument gerade
hier fündig wurde hätte wirklich niemand
von den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern für möglich gehalten
denn diese region das maß ist bekannt
dafür das wasser verdampft ganz einfach
aufgrund der gegebenen druck und
temperaturverhältnisse die vorherrschen
mineralien die in der vergangenheit
gesammelt und analysiert wurden hatten
zum großteil nur wenige prozent wasser
enthalten wie also kann das sein wird
das riesige wasservorkommen unter dem
maßband kennen also auf mysteriöse weise
immer wieder gefüllt oder herrschen an
diesem ort doch besonders günstige
umstände die noch nicht in allen
einzelheiten von der fachwelt verstanden
worden sind besonders spannend ist
dieses wasserreservoir am boden des wall
marie näheres aber vor allem weil es
sich für weitere missionen geradezu
anbietet für ihre aktuelle studie hatten
die forschende beobachtung von mai 2010
bis februar 2021 ausgewertet doch das
ist erst der anfang dazu esa mitarbeiter
haag an
dieser fund ist ein unglaublicher erster
schritt aber wir benötigen mehr
beobachtungen um sicher zu wissen in
welcher form das wasser existiert der
tgo ist teil des esa programms exomars
an dem auch die russische
weltraumagentur roskosmos beteiligt ist
auch anrufer ist angedacht die im
kommenden sommer 2022 endlich zum mars
starten soll eigentlich war der start
des mars so was rosalind fängt dann
bereits für das jahr 2020 vorgesehen
doch aufgrund der korona pandemie
mussten diese pläne verworfen werden die
erwartungshaltung der fachleute ist
riesig mit seiner hilfe soll diese
mission endlich spuren von leben auf dem
roten planeten aufspüren können dafür
ist der hofer unter anderem mit einem
spezialbohrer ausgestattet denn bis zu
zwei meter unter die marsoberfläche
schauen kann außerdem mit an bord ein
labor worin die proben in einer reinen
umgebung analysiert werden können es
geht also für die menschheit weiter
richtung mars und es scheint tatsächlich
nur noch eine frage der zeit zu sein
waren menschen zum ersten mal den roten
planeten betreten werden wasser gibt es
schon mal genügend jetzt fehlt nur noch
eins so wird der mars zur erde
terraforming mit künstlichen magnetfeld
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren das
geht ganz einfach mit dem abo button
unter jedem video bis dann bleibt